all right it's time to do our draft of
the best players in the nfc north chris
you've got the trivia question i hope if
i get it right i get the first pick
all right here we go big guy a green bay
packer has won the nfl mvp award eight
different times which is the second most
of any team in nfl history
which franchise has the most mvp award
winners
it's a good question franchise has the
most mvp award winners well it would
have to be a franchise that's been
around for a while correct
now i don't know how long they've been
handing out the mvp award that's the
problem the mvp award may not be a thing
that's been around since 1920. see if
it's been around since 1920 i would say
the chicago bears if it's a more recent
thing probably not the bears another
team that has been traditionally good
better than not the most but you know
what i'm going to go ahead and say the
bears i'm going to say the bears
it was actually the indianapolis colts
oh my god josh
i know well because peyton manning has
four johnny unitas had three bert jones
won one in 76 and earl morrill won one
and 68 so that was that's a good
question there i did not expect that and
you're right when did the mvp start i
want to say that started what early 60s
but i'm not sure about that yeah late
50s early 60s and when you throw in
peyton manning it makes sense bert jones
that's a blast from the past but i
remember right when the colts because
when i grew up watching football the
first few years the cult stunk right it
was after the united era so i just
looked at the cults and thought oh
they're no good then all of a sudden the
colts are good with bert jones and
company and uh that didn't last very
long until peyton manning ended up
joining the team 20 years later all
right you get the first pick in the
draft
well
i haven't sang this in a while this is
feels good oh thy aaron rodgers
you're the greatest i've ever seen
yep aaron rodgers first pick i mean come
on aaron rodgers uh he's still one of
the five best quarterbacks in all of nfl
even at this age he had an unbelievable
year last year you know we've talked
already during this show that we'd like
to see a little bit better of a
supporting cast around him at the wide
receiver position you know is he aaron
rodgers from three four years ago no
okay but man he can still make some
really really special throws and dance
around the pocket as good as anybody uh
and for me yes that is still the best
player in the nfc north
i have an important question for you
chris
when did the song change from oh aaron
rodgers to oh thy aaron rodgers where
the hell did that come from i don't know
i had to live who do i know i know are
you trying to make sense of what's
working in my brain don't try to do that
you'll just drive yourself crazy
all right uh you know
yesterday we we had so many great
players in the afc north we could have
done 10 rounds um i i
there there aren't a ton of jump off the
page butt kicker great players in the
nfc north right now sorry packers bears
lions vikings but it's true uh i'm going
to go khalil mack right even though
khalil mack was a little bit down last
year he was dominant in his first year
with the bears in 2018 i think if they
can get a little more balance
offensively it'll be more opportunities
for cleo mac to rush the passer you know
adjusting to chuck pagano last year's
defensive coordinator as well but i
think from a talent standpoint khalil
mack one of the members of the team of
the decade even though he was only in
the nfl for half of the decade he's the
guy that we have to look to is the best
defensive player still in the nfc north
yeah i think that's fair i mean he's
still a game changer and i know the
stats you know they're not like
mind-blowing from last year
but you know it meant again they had
akeem hicks hurt for a long period of
time and khalil mack is you know enemy
number one from when a team game plans
to play the bears they go okay
how do we not let number 52 ruin the
football game for us and people
orchestrate game plans around doing that
and that makes life tough so yeah i'm
with you that would have been my pick
mike uh good d good for you all right
i'm going dalvin cook dalvin cook to me
i mean dalvin cooks in the conversation
for the best running back in the nfl
as explosive as he is his ability to
catch a screen and go 70 or bust through
the line of scrimmage on the outside
zone gary kubiak run scheme and you know
put his foot in the ground and come
downhill 100 miles per hour i mean he is
truly one of the best pure runners in
the league and minnesota as you said
many times last year i mean if they
couldn't get the run game going and dow
the good going you know the offense was
iffy at best their their team is
orchestrated about around his ability
and his ability to make plays in the run
game so dalvin cook a game changer
explosive tough bell cow type running
back and uh yes one of the best players
in the nfc north for my money
i'm going to stick with the minnesota
vikings chris and i am not going to take
the guy that you think i would may take
he does not wear number eight for the
vikings he plays defensive line i think
he wears number nine but
999 i should know that if he's as good
as i think i should know his number off
the top of my head danielle hunter
d'neil hunter quietly is one of the most
dominant defensive players in football
why did they not bat an eye at everson
griffin leaving they have danielle
hunter why did not worry about stephen
weatherly joining the carolina panthers
they've got to neil hunter he's the guy
you build your defensive line around he
is a dominant force he single-handedly
derailed the attempt by the saints to
pull out a victory late in the wild card
round when he busted through and blew up
drew brees and got the ball out of his
hands denial hunter for whatever reason
does not get the credit he deserves and
he is truly one of the best defensive
players not just in the conference but
in the entire league and maybe this is
the year that people will stand up and
take notice
yeah i mean i'm with you he is he's one
of the best edge pass rushers in the
league he's got great size athleticism
he's awesome you know hey listen i think
the vikings had a few guys that kind of
fly under the radar as far as that's
concerned you know i i i got eric
kendricks on my list too because i think
he's one of the best middle linebackers
in football but
i don't think i'm going to pick him
you know i'm going to go back to the
bears i'm going to go to akeem hicks all
right it's it's not sexy
but akeem hicks mike and i know you've
heard me talk about him before
you know he's in the conversation for me
with fletcher cox aaron donald chris
jones as being grady jarrett as being
one of the best interior alignment in
all of football i mean he's disruptive
but he's a giant human being and he
really causes issues with any team's run
game so you know i i when i when in
doubt i like to give some love to these
you know the big uglies the big sexies
the offensive defensive lineman and this
is a guy that's been one of the best
defensive players in football the last
few years we don't talk about him a lot
so i'm going to keem hicks in my last
pick
yeah and look you mentioned earlier the
fact that he was injured last year
impacted in a negative way the
performance of khalil mack and and and
hicks was one of the reasons why they
had that special season in 2018 he was
there definitely most of the year if not
all of the year and he continued to get
done by the way daniel hunter does wear
number 99 i was pretty sure that i don't
know it's been a while what kind of
viking fan are you jeez well i'm trying
to prove to you that i'm not as much of
a fan as you accuse me of being i don't
know denial hunter's number off the top
of my head they also have those funky
numbers too that gets back to the whole
thing about the nikification of the nfl
why can't we just have the normal old
numbers why why why not can we just have
can we just have unifor that's why they
call them uniforms let's have a uniform
numbering system in the national
football league please all right i'm
just buying time here because i can't
believe i'm going to do this but i'm
going to do it chris i'm i'm being
objective
i'm being fair
but i'm also being realistic kirk
cousins is the next guy that i have to
take not matthew stafford stafford was
injured last year kirk cousins when
he is
in a position that he has time to throw
the football he can
and he does and he throws it accurately
and we saw him make that throw with the
season on the line in overtime of the
wild card game against the new orleans
saints dropped it in 43-yarder to adam
thielen set up the victory then he threw
the touchdown pass to kyle rudolph if
kirk cousins would have been the 49ers
quarterback boy the 49ers fans are going
to love to hear this if he had been the
49ers cornerback in the super bowl he
would have hit emanuel sanders on that
play where sanders was wide open not
wide open but open enough to hit him if
you're a quarterback who can throw the
ball accurately so i think cousins i
think what it was last year
when stefan diggs went awol after the
loss to the bears i truly think that
that caused something in kirk cousins to
to snap
and and he decided to force himself to a
higher level because i think it hurt him
to go through what he went through with
diggs disappearing for a couple of days
with adam thielen calling him out and he
has pushed himself to a higher level and
i think it's going to continue into
2020.
oh baby i can't believe i just saw you
pick kirk cousins i mean the love hate
continues i love him i love him not i
love him i love him not
it's unbelievable oh but i'm with you he
is so he's so underappreciated he is a
really good football player i don't know
if i would have made him my third pick i
think maybe i would have gone like a
devonte adams or maybe as a darius smith
they were in the running for me as well
but uh your your case in point is very
well done and get off the nike vacation
number thing i mean come on old man
magoo
stop it i'm going to keep talking so
they can't turn this into a clip for
tomorrow
my eyes can't focus on all these little
twists and turns just put numbers on the
jerseys that we can see what the hell
the numbers are that's all i'm asking
for i'm not asking for much all right uh
we're gonna take it right so that hey
fun draft good job and we'll continue it
tomorrow with uh did you even think
about a lions player other than matthew
stafford just before we go
who would it have been
i know
i mean who would have been
maybe him or carry on johnson but i
think it just speaks to the little bit
of the lack of talent detroit right now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports